aufrufe zur waffenruhe außenministers
sichert israel solidarität zu und bringt
im gaza-konflikt auf eine feuerpause
falscher flüchtling vor gericht der
bundeswehroffizier franke hatte sich als
syrer ausgegeben und soll anschläge auf
politiker geplant haben
rückstau bei erstimpfungen das ende der
priorisierung in bayern führt zu
problemen ärzte kritisieren die
aufhebung als zu früh
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und in allen die welt
an diesem donnerstag katja stresow puck
gleich auf den sportlichen teil aber
gerne doch schön und klar an der seite
israels so hat sich der
bundesaußenminister heute gezeigt heiko
maas besucht das land mitten im
gaza-konflikt er will damit vor allem
solidarität zeigen dass hier ist petach
tikva östlich von tel aviv inmitten der
trümmer eines zerstörten gebäudes der
deutsche außenminister er betont israel
habe das recht sich gegen die piraten
angriffe der hamas zu verteidigen seine
bürger zu schützen
er verweist auf die situation der
menschen auf beiden seiten
und er drängt auf eine baldige
waffenruhe die lässt allerdings noch auf
sich warten
das leid der zivilbevölkerung steigt von
tag zu tag besonders im gazastreifen
sind die zerstörungen gewaltig andreas
künast zum ersten mal seit beginn der
korona pandemie wird der deutsche
außenminister wieder mit handschlag
begrüßt mit einer umarmung sogar das
liegt nicht nur an israels imf rekord
sondern vor allem an der botschaft die
heiko maas mitbringt an deutschlands
fast uneingeschränkter solidarität
die rakete schlug in der nacht ein kurz
vor 2 in dieses wohnhaus in petach tikva
heute genau vor einer woche fünf
menschen sind verletzt
heiko maas wird direkt vom flughafen an
die einschlagstelle gefahren es ist das
bild zur botschaft für uns ist die
sicherheit israels und genauso die
sicherheit aller jüdinnen und juden in
deutschland nicht verhandelbar
und darauf kann sich israel immer
verlassen vielen dank
maas übt heute keine kritik an israel
aber er drängt so sehr auf eine
waffenruhe dass netanyahu als antwort
ein trümmerstück zeigen iran hat diese
bewaffnete drohnen geschickt sagt der
premier wir haben sie an der grenze zu
jordanien abgefangen und ich glaube das
sagt alles
dann wählten wechsel von jerusalem durch
den sicherheitszaun nach ramallah
maas will die palästinenser treffen aber
nicht die hamas deutschland redet nicht
mit terroristen um so sitzt neben dem
ziemlich machtlosen präsident abbas ein
ziemlich ratloser heiko maas 2 die nur
appellieren können
als mars vor einer stunde aufbricht
kommt in israel das sicherheitskabinett
zusammen um über eine waffenruhe zu
beraten ohne vorfestlegung und ohne
gäste aus dem ausland
und dann bringen wir unseren
korrespondenten in washington mit dazu
elmar theveßen guten namen der elmer
wesentlich mehr einfluss auf israel als
der deutsche außenminister haben die usa
allein schon wegen der
milliardenschweren militärhilfe für
israel und präsident beiden von dem hört
man jetzt andere töne so eine art macht
wird ja in einem telefonat ein sehr
klares signal einer aufforderung an
netanjahu sofort zu deeskalieren weil
eben die historische unterstützung für
israels regierungspolitik hier aus den
usa ein stück weit gerade ins wanken
kommt joe biden steht unter massivem
druck auch innerhalb seiner eigenen
partei namhafte abgeordnete fordern die
sofortige einstellung der militärhilfe
weil netanjahu in den vergangenen jahren
durch seine siedlungspolitik eine
zweistaatenlösung im nahen osten fast
unmöglich gemacht hat und es regt sich
auch immer mehr kritik innerhalb der
jüdischen gemeinschaft besonders bei
jungen menschen in den usa die sich für
black live meter engagiert haben also
gegen die diskriminierung von schwarzen
deshalb kritisieren sie auch sehr offen
die diskriminierung von palästinensern
niemand zweifelt hier in den usa
natürlich am recht israels sich gegen
die angriffe der terroristischen hamas
zu verteidigen
aber diese unerschütterliche
unterstützung die es eben nicht mehr
selbstverständlich und deshalb wird die
beiden auch weiter druck machen auf
beide seiten interessante analyse aus
washington hemmer herzlichen dank dafür
gegen jeden antisemitismus solidarität
mit israel ist das motto jetzt gerade in
berlin vor dem brandenburger tor
seit ein paar minuten läuft dort eine
umgebung jüdische organisationen auch
viele andere haben dazu aufgerufen
sprechen sollen spitzen politiker fast
aller parteien aus dem deutschen
bundestag
das soll eine botschaft seien gegen den
hass auf juden der zeigt sich in
deutschland mitunter bei anti israel
protesten
er zeigt sich aber auch im alltag auf
der straße in der schule auf dem
fußballplatz berichtet susanne santina
nina ist alleinerziehend und macht sich
oft sorgen um ihre vier kinder vor allem
um den achtjährigen luke weil der beim
jüdischen fußballverein makkabi
frankfurt spielt sein vereins pulli mit
dem davidstern darf er nur tragen wenn
er nicht mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln fahren muss dort wurden
sie oft beschimpft
scheiß juden solche dinge die haben wir
halt oft erlebt ich muss sagen es gibt
mittlerweile für uns juden hier in
deutschland leider so no go gegenden wo
ich auch wirklich mit den kindern
durchlaufe und einfach merke mich selber
erwische mich direkten demokratie jacke
mit aus dem auto also das passiert mir
oft antisemitismus würden sie alle schon
lange erleben
deswegen seien sie auch nicht über die
judenfeindlichen demos in den letzten
tagen überrascht
das ist schon beängstigend ich finde
jeder sollte jede politik so wie weit er
will kritisieren können es wird nur eben
dann problematisch wo das existenzrecht
israels irgendwie grundsätzlich einfach
aberkannt wird judenfeindliche
erfahrungen machen auch die fußballer
von makkabi buluk spielt nur weil es ein
jüdischer fußballverein sei würden seine
jungs ständig beleidigt sagt der trainer
als jude verpiss dich verpiss dich aus
frankfurt und ich mich jedes mal frage
wie tief verankert ist es seinen eltern
auch mal die müssen es ja den kindern
weitergeben es kommt kein 9 oder 10
jährige auf die idee auf einmal
antisemitische kommentare abzulassen
ninas sohn lennox überlegt nach israel
auszuwandern eine schwere entscheidung
weil ich mich deutsch fühle und ich will
hier eigentlich nicht weg aber natürlich
muss man sich in irgendeiner art und
weise damit beschäftigen nina ist
enttäuscht von der deutschen
mehrheitsgesellschaft sagt sie sie würde
sich mehr solidarität wünschen damit sie
als juden in deutschland sicher leben
könnten
unser nächstes thema jetzt gestern der
rücktritt heute die entlassungsurkunde
familienministerin franziska giffey
wurde vom bundespräsidenten offiziell
verabschiedet sie hat ihren schritt mit
den plagiatsvorwürfen um ihre
doktorarbeit begründet gefallen spd
spitzenkandidatin für die wahl zum
berliner abgeordnetenhaus im september
bleiben
das familienministerium übernimmt
christine lambrecht zusätzlich zu ihrem
amt als justizministerin ein
oberleutnant der bundeswehr steht seit
heute vor dem oberlandesgericht
frankfurt franco ist angeklagt weil er
so der vorwurf aus einer zutiefst
rechtsextremistischen gesinnung heraus
anschläge auf politiker verüben wollte
gleichzeitig führte franco ein
doppelleben er hatte eine zweite
identität als syrischer asylbewerber dem
wollte er laut anklage die anschläge
anschließend in die schuhe schieben
stefan schlosser frank urban sich heute
seinen weg ins gericht durch einen pulk
von journalisten seit dem ende der
untersuchungshaft ist der unter auflagen
auf freiem fuß ins visier der ermittler
gerät eher 2017 als er auf einer
toilette im wiener flughafen eine zuvor
selbst versteckte waffe an sich nehmen
will
die polizei erwartet ihn
die folgenden ermittlungen lassen
vermuten dass franco a terror anschläge
plante er soll einen anschlag
vorbereitet haben möglicherweise auf den
damaligen justizminister heiko maas oder
die damalige vize bundestagspräsident in
claudia roth oder eine
menschenrechtsaktivistin franco a führte
ein doppelleben hatte sich eine zweite
identität zugelegt als syrischer
flüchtlinge
die bundesanwaltschaft ist sich sicher
frank war wollte nach einem anschlag den
verdacht auf flüchtlinge lenken
immer wieder suchte oft den kontakt zu
medien um seine version der geschichte
zu erzählen
auch den zdf gegenüber demnach habe er
nur auf missstände im deutschen
asylsystem aufmerksam machen wollen
politische entscheidung und behörden
handeln so groß geworden dass das zu
einem zu einer konfliktsituation geführt
hat mit dem eigenen schuhe
deshalb habe ich das verfahren
durchlaufen und die beobachtungen
erkenntnisse daraus dokumentarisch
festgehalten
der fall des oberleutnants löst
untersuchungen von rechten strukturen in
der bundeswehr und anderen
sicherheitsbehörden aus verschiedenen
netzwerke werden aufgedeckt zu denen
auch frank o a gehörten die
rechtsextremistische gesinnung von
franco a dürfte prozess einfach zu
beweisen sein anhand seiner
aufzeichnungen für eine verurteilung
bedarf es aber mehr
das gericht muss zu dem schluss kommen
dass er zu terroranschlägen fest
entschlossen war im falle einer
verurteilung drohen frank ua bis zu zehn
jahre haft
und jetzt in der sendung die korona lage
in deutschland die bundesweite sieben
tage inzidenz sinkt weiter und liegt
jetzt bei 68 das robert koch institut
meldet 12 1298 neuinfektionen innerhalb
von 24 stunden das sind rund 5000
weniger als vergangenen donnerstag
seit einem monat weniger ansteckungen
dagegen ist die zahl der todesfälle
immer noch recht hoch heute sind es 237
intensivmediziner begründen das damit
dass zwischen infektion und tod bis zu
sechs wochen liegen können millionen
impfwillige haben sich gefreut als sie
die nachricht gehört haben die
priorisierung feld bundesweit zum
siebten juni
doch die praxis zeigt bei den erst
impfungen gibt es jetzt bereits einen
gewaltigen stau und frust denn die
nachfrage ist viel höher als das angebot
2,5 millionen dosen werden pro woche an
die zentren geliefert das zeigen die
zahlen des bundesgesundheitsministeriums
die hausärzte bekommen ab dieser woche
ebenfalls knapp 2,5 millionen ende juni
sollen es dann immerhin 3,7 millionen
pro woche seien aus bayern jetzt
patricia schäfer keine neuen impftermine
mehr im bamberger impfzentrum denn der
impfstoff reicht nur noch für die zweit
impfungen ähnlich im im zentrum freising
die vereinbarten erste impfungen werden
noch gemacht
aber der löwenanteil nämlich 70 prozent
sind im moment zwei impfungen
dadurch dass wir verpflichtet sind die
zweitimpfung durchzuführen kommt
natürlich zu einem kleinen rückstau bei
den erst impfungen kleiner rückstau
das heißt dass in bayerischen
impfzentren in den nächsten zwei bis
drei wochen keine neuen impftermine
vergeben werden dieser rückschlag kommt
während in den arztpraxen die
priorisierung wird heute entfällt damit
wurden hoffnungen geweckt dass jeder
sich bald impfen lassen kann
ein vorschneller schritt der bayerischen
staatsregierung dass wir jetzt sagen wir
sind flexibel und der arzt vor ort kann
das selber entscheiden mit seinem team
wir das macht das halte ich nach wie vor
für richtig
doch bei den impfwilligen hat sich
dadurch eine erwartungshaltung aufgebaut
die nun nicht erfüllt werden kann
denn seit wochen liegen die termine der
anstehenden zweit impfungen fest und
nach wie vor fehlt dass ein impfstoff
dass mehr impfstoff kommt dass wir
parallel zu den zwei impfungen auch erst
informieren wochen können erst ab dem
siebten juni soll es in bayern mehr
impfstoff geben das hätte die politik
besser kommunizieren können
vor der sommersaison haben sich die
eu-länder und das eu-parlament auf ein
europa weiteres zertifikat geeinigt zum
nachweis von kona impfungen tests und
überstandenen cupid 19 erkrankungen
strittig war im vorfeld vor allem die
frage ob impfpass inhaber noch in
quarantäne müssen oder krüger beobachtet
das für uns in brüssel wunder kann der
eu impfpass denn jetzt auch rechtzeitig
zur reisesaison kommen ja er kann kommen
und die nachricht ist nur wenige minuten
alt die einigung ist auch typisch
brüssel rat kommission und parlament
mussten sich hier ja einigen und hatten
sich an zwei punkten verhakt das
parlament wollte dass die pcr test für
all die die noch keinen impfangebot
bekommen haben dass diese pcr tests
umsonst sein sollen oder dass sie auch
umsonst bleiben die mitgliedstaaten
hätten das bezahlen wollten und wollten
dass das bezahlen müssen aber wollten es
nicht und so hat man nun heilung
gefunden mit geld aus der kasse der
kommission 100 millionen euro für tests
für
einkommensschwache und für berufspendler
3.2 weil die einigung schon schwieriger
gerade bei der frage der quarantäne die
parlamentarier wollten dass ein grüner
haken auf der app auch wirklich
reisefreiheit bedeutet dabei die
mitgliedsstaaten wollten sich dieses
instrument von quarantäne oder test sich
nicht aus der hand nehmen lassen gerade
mit verweis zum beispiel auf hotspots
eben in großbritannien und nun ist der
kompromiss eben klassisch größe man sagt
wenn das solche restriktionen nur auf
basis auf strenger basis von
wissenschaftlichen fakten erlassen in
dem punkt hat sich also das parlament
ein wenig durch gesetz insgesamt aber
muss man sagen haben sich die
mitgliedsstaaten durchgesetzt übrigens
auch mit der forderung nach einer
sechswöchigen übergangsfrist es gibt zum
beispiel deutschland die zeit digitale
noch ein bisschen nachzuarbeiten
an vielen tagen schwieriges thema
wichtiges thema auch gut dass es zum eu
impfpass um 19 uhr 30 ein zdf heute live
gibt in der zdf- heute- erb und zum
mitdiskutieren auf unseren social media
kanälen
gute nachrichten für die mitarbeiter des
ferienfliegers condor der hat einen
neuen investor gefunden laut condor will
der deutsche vermögensverwalter testor
51 prozent der anteile übernehmen und
450 millionen euro investieren
die 4050 arbeitsplätze blieben erhalten
condor war schon vor der pandemie in
schieflage geraten und durch staatliche
zuschüsse gerettet worden
urheberrecht im internet das war bisher
ungeregelt und ein problem für verlage
und künstler heute hat der bundestag
einer reform zugestimmt
plattformbetreiber wie youtube oder
facebook sollen nun haften wenn nutzer
unerlaubt ohne urheberrechtlich
geschützte texte oder videos hochladen
während die einen die reform beklatschen
sprechen andere von internetzensur pablo
sie lala hiermit einzuhalten
internetgiganten wie youtube müssen nach
der urheberrechtsreform künftig notfalls
inhalte löschen
um zu verhindern dass illegale inhalte
hochgeladen werden sollen so genannte
upload filter eingesetzt werden kritiker
befürchten dadurch eine zensur
durch die urheberrechtsreform werden
upload filter jetzt für bestimmte
plattformen verpflichtend und ich
befürchte dass es dadurch vermehrt zur
sperrung illegaler inhalte kommen wird
und das ist eine einschränkung der
meinungsfreiheit und so funktionieren
die upload filter wer künftig etwa musik
fotos oder videos in sozialen netzwerken
teilen will könnte dann eine
fehlermeldung zu sehen bekommen denn
urheberrechtlich geschützte inhalte
werden dann automatisch gefiltert und
aussortiert vor zwei jahren gingen in
ganz europa junge menschen gegen die
upload filter auf die straße doch der
protest blieb weitgehend wirkungslos die
eu verabschiedet eine regelung die jetzt
vom bundestag umgesetzt worden ist
allerdings in abgemilderter form dieser
versuch ist vermutlich gelungen denn es
ist wirklich ein kompromiss bei dem man
sagen kann die rechte der nutzer und
auch der urheber wurde einigermaßen in
abwägung gebracht große medien verlage
und die musikbranche begrüßen die reform
grundsätzlich jetzt müssen rechteinhaber
und plattformen über die genauen
modalitäten verhandeln dabei geht es um
viel geld
jetzt geht es um viel sport hat ja
samstag letzter spieltag in der fußball
bundesliga und da sorgt der
abstiegskampf für spannung verfolgt
eickel in die zweite liga bielefeld
bremen oder der erste fc köln fc trainer
friedhelm funkel sagt die anspannung und
der focus steigen mit jedem tag
es ist auf dem papier eine vermeintlich
lösbare aufgabe für trainer friedhelm
funkel gegen den tabellenletzten zu
gewinnen
allerdings hatte schalke vergangene
woche gegen frankfurt plötzlich wieder
erstliga qualitäten gezeigt und mit dem
4 3-sieg der eintrag den einzug in die
champions league vereitelt also wir
werden alles andere als schalke
unterschätzen haben überhaupt überhaupt
keinen grund zu
und das wäre respektlos
der vorletzte der tabelle hat den
verbleib in der ersten liga nicht selbst
in der hand köln muss gewinnen und
darauf hoffen dass die anderen
abstiegskandidaten bielefeld und bremen
genau dies nicht tun
immerhin stürmer sebastian anders sein
und kapitän jonas hector kehren am
samstag zurück um mitzuhelfen den
siebten abstieg des ersten fc köln zu
verhindern
wir sind wieder auf kurs freute sich
jürgen klopp nach dem 3 zu 0 sieg seines
fc liverpool gegen den fc burnley in der
englischen premier league liverpool
hatte es vor dem letzten spieltag wieder
in der eigenen hand sich für die
champions league zu qualifizieren
das hier ist vorfreude auf die champions
league jürgen klopps jubel hat seine
gründe
denn anfang märz noch waren seine reds
bis auf tabellenplatz acht durchgereicht
worden
doch gestern beim fc burnley gab es den
vierten sieg in folge für mini mit dem 1
0 zur pausenführung nach dem wechsel
dann noch zwei weitere tore hat philips
hier mit dem 20
und schließlich oxlade chamberlain mit
dem solo zum 3 0 endstand
noch ist nichts entschieden wir haben
unsere position leicht verbessert und
wir haben das saisonfinale dass wir
brauchten am sonntag gegen crystal
palace hat klopp für den notfall ja auch
noch seinen torhüter als möglichen
torschützen stimmt der köpft er im
letzten spiel in der nachspielzeit
liverpool noch zum sieg wie lang hat ja
so jetzt haben wir für sie noch eine
antwort auf die wirklich sehr wichtige
frage was haben eiffelturm und grand
canyon gemeinsam beides super fotomotive
ab jetzt sogar zusammen in einem bild
das pariser wahrzeichen thront über
einem abgrundtiefen riesenkrake eine
gigantische illusion geschaffen von dem
französischen künstler dr
blickfang für alle fotobegeisterten
pariser und deren gäste wetter übrigens
nicht so gut in paris habe ich gesehen
bei uns ist es ähnlich viel wind viel
wechsel aber wenigstens ein bisschen
wärmer die details gleich von katja
honnefer dann empfehle ich ihnen
natürlich das heute journal um 21 uhr 45
die kollegin marietta slomka hat frei
fragen an den bundesaußenminister in
israel morgen sind wir wieder für sie da
hier um sieben bis dann und in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das
sturmtief marco hat inzwischen
großbritannien erreicht und es brachte
schon heute schwere sturmböen und
orkanartige sturmböen mit
windgeschwindigkeiten also von hundert
oder sogar 108 kilometer pro stunde
dieses steht tief macht sich auch bei
uns in deutschland bemerkbar
weniger mit dem wind sondern mehr mit
den regenfällen schon heute danach gibt
es kräftige schauer zum teil auch
gewitter im norden deutschlands und hier
im südwesten in baden württemberg da
beginnt es kräftig zu regnen
im kräftigen südwind bleibt die nacht
recht mit die temperaturen sinken auf 12
bis 7 grad und nur in nieder und
oberbayern geht auf 5 bis 4 grad runter
höchsttemperaturen morgen dinge etwas
höher als heute
bei 13 grad am alpenrand sonst werden
oft 14 bis 18 grad erreicht aber hier im
nordosten geht sogar auf 20 bis 21 grad
drauf allerdings bleibt es sehr
wechselhaft besonders in der nordhälfte
entwickeln sich kräftige schauer und
gewitter bei einem recht stürmischen
wind aus südwestlichen richtungen
und hier richtung alpenrand und auch
richtung schwarzwald da schüttelt es zum
teil ergiebig zwischendurch zeigt sich
aber auch die sonne und wechselhaft geht
es dann auch am samstag pfingstsonntag
und pfingstmontag weiter der
pfingstmontag wird wurde der
freundlichste tag bei temperaturen bis
21 grad